Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Si la vie vous donne des citrons,
faites de la citronnade.
Ce proverbe nous rappelle
que dans l'adversité,
nous avons su innover
et créer avec ce que nous avons.
La vie nous a donné l'eau,
et l'eau nous a donné la vie.
Et on a appris à faire
beaucoup plus que la citronnade.
On manque désormais d'eau :
pas d'eau, pas de citronnade.
Nous faisons face
à une crise mondiale de l'eau.
Mais aujourd'hui je veux
que nous voyions ensemble
que nous avons des solutions
à cette crise.
En 2020, le Forum économique mondial
a classé la crise mondiale de l'eau
parmi les 10 plus grands
risques pour l'humanité,
l'estimant avec un impact plus important
que la propagation
d'une maladie infectieuse
et plus probable qu'une crise financière.
C'est une ressource si vitale
que l'ONU a consacré l'accès à l'eau
comme un droit fondamental.
Il n'en existe pas de substitut.
Chacun de nous mourrions
en quelques jours seulement sans elle.
L'économie s'arrêterait,
les citrons ne pousseraient plus.
Depuis des millénaires,
notre prospérité dépend de la confiance
qu'on peut avoir de l'eau à boire.
Nous vivons sur la planète bleue et
70 % de sa surface est recouverte d'eau.
Mais l'eau douce dont nos vies dépendent,
légèrement moins.
97 % de l'eau sur la surface
du globe est de l'eau salée.
2 % constituent la banquise
et il ne reste que 1 % de l'eau
présente sur la surface du globe
sous la forme d'eau douce liquide,
dont plus des deux tiers sont
sous terre et difficiles à accéder.
Il nous reste donc une quantité d'eau
qui tiendrait dans une sphère
de la taille de l'Inde
pour boire, se laver,
faire pousser notre nourriture,
les ressources pour nos habitations
et nos vêtements.
Nous nous sommes développés
grâce à l'utilisation de l'eau en surface.
Comme les grandes villes de France
présentes sur les fleuves.
Avec la maîtrise de nos ressources,
bien que limitées,
nous nous sommes développés
considérablement.
Mais, au début du dernier siècle,
après des décennies d'innovation dans
les infrastructures et l'assainissement,
nous avons réalisé une prouesse :
nous avons commencé
à installer l'eau courante.
On ouvre à un robinet
et hop, de l'eau propre.
Sept personnes sur dix ont de l'eau
qui coule directement chez eux.
Mais ça, c'est le verre à moitié plein.
Le verre à moitié vide, c'est que
3 personnes sur 10 n'ont pas cette chance.
Et ce verre à moitié vide
pourrait devenir complètement vide.
On n'a pas achevé cette prouesse
dans la gestion de l'eau.
Nous l'avons initiée
il y a plus de 100 ans
et encore plus de 2 milliards
de personnes en sont privées.
2 milliards.
Difficile de [compter] le nombre de vies
et d'histoires que ça représente.
Pour se l'imaginer, un milliard
de secondes, c'est 32 ans.
Si nous pouvions regarder
ces 100 milliards d'histoires,
vie par vie, ne serait-ce qu'une seconde,
il nous faudrait toute une vie
pour voir les leurs défiler.
800 millions de personnes n'ont
même pas accès à l'eau potable.
Imaginez la population
de l'Union Européenne et des États-Unis
sans accès à ce besoin basique.
Ainsi en 2015,
l'ONU a établi l'accès à l'eau
et à l'assainissement
comme l'un des 17 objectifs
de développement durable.
Ces objectifs représentent les défis
les plus importants de notre société
avec la lutte contre la faim,
la lutte contre la pauvreté,
l'accès à l'éducation ou
l'égalité entre les sexes.
Établir une eau propre
et l'assainissement pour tous
est autant l'un des plus grands défis
mais aussi l'une des solutions.
Améliorer son accès est ainsi un levier
pour améliorer la santé, l'éducation,
l'égalité, le développement
de ces milliards d'histoires.
Les maladies liées à l'eau sont
une des plus grandes causes de
mortalité infantile dans le monde.
Selon l'OMS,
la diarrhée tue plus de 500 000 enfants
de moins de cinq ans tous les ans.
Un enfant meurt chaque minute
d'une maladie que l'on sait prévenir
et traiter à moindre coût.
Cela cause malnutrition et déshydratation
avec des conséquences sur la santé
et l'égalité des chances des enfants.
Un enfant malade marchant des heures
pour trouver de l'eau ne va pas à l'école.
Les femmes sont plus touchées
par cette conséquence
car elles sont souvent responsables
d'aller collecter l'eau.
C'est plus de 200 millions
d'heures par jour
dédiées à cette activité
[au niveau mondial].
Ce sont des heures précieuses
pour développer d'autres activités
et pendant lesquelles
nos filles s'éloignent de l'école.
Chaque euro investi
dans l'eau et l'assainissement
en rapportera quatre
avec des coûts de santé moindres,
par une augmentation de la productivité,
et une diminution des morts prématurées.
Ce sont 250 milliards d'euros qui
seraient sauvés chaque année.
Tout cela est possible
en développant des techniques de
filtration et d'assainissement adaptées.
Toutes les idées sont nécessaires
pour vaincre cette crise mondiale
car nous avons tort de penser
qu'il y a un « eux » et un « nous ».
Il n'y a pas de « eux » car ce fardeau
va bientôt tomber sur nos épaules.
Sept personnes sur dix
ont accès à l'eau chez elles,
mais ce verre commence à se vider,
et ça pourrait ne plus être le cas.
Nous étions 1,6 milliard en 1900 ;
nous sommes aujourd'hui 7,8 milliards ;
et chaque année, 80 millions de personnes
viennent agrandir notre société.
Mais avec notre petit
pourcent d'eau disponible,
les calculs ne sont pas bons.
En un siècle,
notre consommation d'eau
a été multipliée par sept
et dépasse la quantité d'eau
disponible en surface.
On a donc appris à atteindre
les eaux souterraines, les aquifères.
Mais ils mettent des millénaires
à se remplir.
Ce sont nos comptes épargne
et là, nous vivons à crédit.
Selon l'institut mondial des ressources,
entre 3 et 5 milliards de personnes
pourraient manquer d'eau d'ici cinq ans.
De nombreuses villes dans le monde se
préparent à cette situation avant 10 ans :
Mexico, Melbourne, Pékin,
Tokyo, Londres ou encore Barcelone.
Être conscient de cette situation est la
première étape pour trouver des solutions.
On connaît la consommation
pour l'hygiène :
deux litres par jour pour boire,
trois litres pour se laver les mains,
50 pour une douche.
Cette consommation, associée
aux droits fondamentaux de l'ONU,
compte pour moins de 10%
de la consommation d'eau mondiale.
La part du lion revient à l'agriculture,
qui compte pour 70%
de la consommation d'eau mondiale.
Ce sont les 2 500 litres d'eau
nécessaires pour faire pousser le coton
pour un seul t-shirt,
ou pour faire un kilo de lentilles.
L'agriculture a besoin d'eau,
il y a une communauté de près
de 8 milliards de personnes à nourrir.
Plus les 50 milliards d'animaux
d'élevage que nous mangeons chaque année.
En même temps, une vache consomme
12 kg de fourrage par jour,
faire pousser un kilo de ce fourrage
nécessite 500 lignes d'eau.
Au final, 15 000 litres d'eau sont
nécessaires pour avoir un kilo de bœuf.
La majeure partie de notre ressource si
vitale est ainsi utilisée pour l'élevage.
C'est donc un combat à livrer plus
dans l'assiette que dans le verre
car nos besoins vont s'accroître.
L'UNESCO a estimé que d'ici 2050,
nos besoins en nourriture
auront augmenté de 70%.
Ainsi, en étant le premier
vecteur du manque d'eau,
l'agriculture et l'élevage sont
aussi l'une des premières solutions.
Enfin, l'eau est utilisée
pour l'industrie.
La construction, par exemple,
est gourmande en eau.
Avec l'augmentation de la population,
nous allons bâtir l'équivalent de New York
tous les mois
pendant les 40 prochaines années.
Ce sont là aussi des défis
que nous pouvons surmonter
avec des innovations dans les procédés,
dans les matériaux,
ou encore dans le design
de nos espaces de vie,
pour avoir des choix par défaut
plus économes en eau.
On ne voit pas la consommation en eau de
ses activités car on ne la paye pas.
On paye seulement l'infrastructure qui
permet de l'amener jusqu'au robinet.
Sans signal sur la valeur économique
de cette ressource précieuse,
aucun individu, entreprise,
industrie ou gouvernement
n'a de raison d'arrêter la fuite.
Mais avec sa raréfaction, c'est l'occasion
de rappeler sa valeur sans égal.
En innovant dans la détection des fuites,
la réutilisation de l'eau,
la prévenance de la pollution,
nous pouvons garantir que nous aurons
de la nourriture dans nos assiettes
et de l'eau dans nos verres.
C'est une nécessité
car c'est autant la bonne chose à faire
que la chose intelligente à faire.
Je suis optimiste pour le futur,
ce challenge est à portée de nos mains.
Certes, on a besoin
de milliers d'innovations,
mais nécessité est mère d'invention.
Parce que l'amélioration de l'accès
à l'eau améliore la santé globale,
l'accès à l'éducation,
l'accès à la nourriture, l'utilisation
des ressources pour la construction,
le transport ou l'énergie,
ce sont autant de chaînons indispensables,
pour que les communautés
continuent de s'élever.
La vie nous a donné l'eau
alors continuons d'en faire
bien plus que de la citronnade.